hello everybody and welcome yeah anyway
my name is markiplier and welcome to
scp-087 B now this is different from
what I played before which was just
scp-087 oh this is so much darker I have
a flashlight or anything nope oh boy
Oh Oh where's this oh here's the stairs
I was wondering cuz this whole thing is
just a stairwell right oh this is
completely different I can't even see
anything what done this is not like what
I had anticipated I anticipated this was
gonna be more you know the stairwell
deal oh ha ha ha ha at least when I go
down one at a time it goes down to a
whole nother floor before I had to loop
back through you know to to go down to a
floor like a normal
it's a good luck radio communication
difficult or something no joke
ah oh why didn't they give me a light
oh now is it the same I can't go back up
I can go back up for some reason I
remember before I couldn't go back
upstairs
not that I'm gonna I'm gonna keep
pushing down I go down as far as I can
oh I do not like oh that sounded like a
mannequin statue or something scraping
towards me but I doubt that will happen
in this one now the description said
that it had more randomized events more
rooms which is weird I don't know if
there's like rooms in this either way
there should be a lot more to this and I
can already tell there is ok number 10
hey I made it to 10 go me oh oh oh no
okay 11 okay
sounds like something
go away
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh and this game was like
2.9 Meg's to download I can't I don't
know why there's so much stuff in here
still going still going still going 15
whoa what done something changed what
what ha ha ha what is this huh what why
why did that happen that way that it was
what things are being different miss hmm
okay all right I can deal with this I
can deal with this I'm tough and
handsome and smart and brave I can do
this you believe in your right you
believe in me don't you ah you okay
I believe in me not good damn it
I don't even know what that was I don't
have anything to say about that
I have no commentary on that whatever
that was not that way oh good golly I
don't know he was like some it was a
figure or something that popped up in
front of me 20 ah oh man
you
okay only six minutes
god dammit
oh oh no I made it to 20 okay firing it
back up and go this is so much worse
this is so much worse so much worse than
the other one this is like ten blue
jillion times worse than the other one I
am oh okay
I can do this I know what to expect now
unless it's just gonna be completely
randomized again I don't even know what
that was I only caught like up what I'm
at three already and now it changed and
it was like I don't know I I barely
caught a glimpse of its face but it was
weird I don't know I walked right into I
thought it was behind me and it was just
in front of me
I don't even know I don't even know what
it was oh this is so much worse okay
it's starting off with the weird hallway
designs right away it's not a
standardized staircase okay all right I
got this shut up
would you knock shut up shut up I
remember that I remember that no it
sounds like that's right on my neck I
don't know how it comes out for you guys
but that sounds like right on my neck
I didn't hear that before okay all right
okay okay okay turn yeah it sounds like
it's right there how can there be such
high quality sounds and stuff in 2.9
Meg's whoo this is real that's just
taking over my computer if that if that
I hear the sound and everything goes
blurry again like I did before I'm just
gonna turn around and run okay all right
well I mean I can't run by my turn
around go the opposite direction yeah
I'm okay
I am a rock
shut up shut up shut up shop I am the
man ah um marker blur huh yeah okay
nothing haven't seen before
no I hate everything about this I hate
this so much I hate everything
everything about this I want it all the
end
okay oh oh man oh man oh man the things
I do for you guys and gals oh all the
things I put myself through Oh God I
survived though he didn't get me
whatever he will he/she it was didn't
get me oh man honey yeah I think I died
right on twenty last time oh I'm gonna
be like doing this for a hundred more
floors because I'm gonna I actually know
how to run away from him now and then
it'll be fine
and then I'll beat the game
oh all right that's enough
no more that you wanna mess with me
flamey-o get your get yeah come on get
your mom come get you
well you think that now I'm gonna get
you
ha ha ha you can't they're for me um I'm
the man
ah Do You Know Who I am I'm a moderately
popular youtuber ah I've got I've got
tens tens of you were more than that
buddy yeah yeah oh my god getting ah
it'd be almost impossible to beat this
game just cuz it takes so much friggin
time if your heart could take it getting
all the way down I suppose it'd be quite
a feat but alright
yeah even those the worst that was the
worst game ever played in my life oh my
god oh I want to go back just a dice
safe amnesia please I want to go back to
some nice safe you know cry of fear
that's not scary
oh can i play dead space again oh boy I
love that game okay
all that time anyway maybe close you'll
forgive me if I don't go back in again
oh god oh oh yeah that was so much
better than the other one cuz I saw him
first on floor 17 I didn't know that he
would pop up behind me like that anyway
sorry for putting now enough for so long
because I was incredible holy crap
anyway boy if you want me to play it
again but if you want me to play it
again let me know I'll think about it
I think about real hard and maybe maybe
I'll come back to it alright anyway so
thank you everybody so much for watching
how that was that was a ride that was
that was a rush that was something sheer
snow's beyond anything I've ever played
before so thank you all so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye
you